you
the bird is the word I guess we can say
it's the bird tournament it's also April
Fool's 2016 and I am going berserk in
every game in this tournament a
difficult task to say the least
oh man in my computer's crawling that's
not a good sign
alright looking for some trades ooh
extra slow man extra slow my bishop
takes h7 if they take that pawn maybe I
should have pinpointed f7 hmm get my H
pawn rolling okay I think that's a
desirable move okay I'm going to break
this down winning no this has to be
winning I want to take the knight and go
into e7 got the Queen oh do I have time
though um
oh there's Bishop check ouch
um oh I was so close oh man
ah man my my computer's crawling some -
that's not cool
hmm I felt it more in this uh first time
oh wait no no no I have to bruise arc
jeez I almost forgot to press arc so mad
with you okay
oh all right here we go
here we go Castle buddy Castle
they berserk - so no no let's take with
the Queen eh - yes back to tournament
land gimme that three oh that one was a
really quick pairing really quick I
might have to go for scholars mate stuff
let's open it up break open the position
that's a free pawn yes that's a piece
yeah I could have taken with the night
let's do it now two pieces
Queenie 2 ani4 Queen trade would be fine
usually I think oh they resigned back to
tournament got six first two threes take
it alright not bad not bad
um yeah I was going to say I think I
want to keep the Queen's on the board
because I need some quick wins I can't
rely upon the time as much oh we might
get paired up again he just finished no
the Carroll con that's the way to do it
and in these right I guess quick
move in alright maybe we could play
against their king or even open up in
the center now that there's some tension
here it'd be really careful bishop move
throw my knight on e4 maybe expand
let's stop Knight b5 first looking for
g4 this is a winning attack ooh
missed that one but I'm actually
smashing through Queen check here take
that
okay that's mate back to Turman whoo
that's a 5-2 that's my third win in a
row I like getting these extra points I
got 1111 5 4 4 mmm all right ah let's
see plenty of time left
mm-hmm oh boy isolated pun having
difficulty free moving I give you 5 in
we're going to do a little dance I guess
they're going to come right at me I got
a break on the Queen side let's take
some time out to stop g4 maybe hmm
don't know if this is really a good idea
let's come here know what I want to do
want to inch in here with my bishop No
this is the right way is very positional
16 seconds and they're looking too
and up the G file I'll take perpetual
perpetual I'll take it
max turrets I'm so tough time uh so down
on time okay
I'm still up there I'm on I'm not on
fire but I'll take the two thirteen nine
eight berserk again I gotta watch out
for those sneaky you know early Bishop
take Knight Bishop takes Knight moves
there right now let's get on the
diagonal with my bishop v6 fish should
be seven I'm going to play C for soon c5
let's get this guy rolling oh boy it's a
good thing my queen is defended oh my
god I should just resign
ouch fork town I'm still in first
somehow else early wins 335 John Madden
alrighty let's open this up my bishop is
a loose piece Castle yeah and do one of
those that night out of there oh no no
no this move is smooth first and then go
here get the dart some dark square
pressure maybe okay
Bishop takes pawn and get some free
moves in oh boy
it's not going to work out yeah it's not
happening I'm really missing my queen
got nothing i got nothing could even
take the rook mm-hmm
nine seconds gonna crash through oh I
didn't want to do that
five seconds go go go
Oh down that time I thought to fix this
I don't know if you could tell either
it's really dragging these pieces trying
to move I don't think I've ever had this
happen before
mmm terrible timing terrible timing to
have them dragging like that ah okay
quit making excuses play better chess
how about that don't lose material touch
off your queen with check you think
you're just an excuse artists all of a
sudden oh that's what you are all right
let's get that night out of there there
we go let's secure my dark square bishop
you should also develop No get
developing man here he'll probably need
some support yeah I got some tricky
stuff here
rook there still rook here if Knight
takes pawn catching up
clock some queen trade alright better
not play Rexy one
I got a gamble I need some I need some
fast moves even on the clock
there we go all right I got my Bishop
defended okay I should have this one
this one shouldn't be an issue
alright never going to play Bishop f3
hmm really no dropping a piece just
don't get made it whatever happens
clothes getting mated it's this
ridiculous 22 17 16 16 16 ah tie for
third
Oh Godzilla just gotta hit the speed
bump there he lost his fire John Madden
again okay oh man yeah he's gonna gonna
come all in at me here could take there
okay play f6 hmm and pinpoint f7 yikes
Knight f4 could take here very important
pawn bishop takes hmm take that
bishop maybe Oh on the Queen I want to
take here and then play something okay
this should be winning now do I have the
time to do it mate threat here no that's
a check you dummy on the Queen three
seconds that was not a good one
I have mate finally oh man back to
tournament I got that one two wings in a
row this next one is really important I
need to get five points please don't let
it be a strong pairing ah that I got a
berserk there you go
you just a pre-move machine aren't you
you're just a pre-move machine there you
go are you going to take that bishop hit
their queen let's go here there you go I
should have taken the night there you go
just give up give away free pawns right
hmm let's pin that's a pin night let's
keep them in a pin there
just drop that man don't end up in a
fork mm-hmm
need to get a good King position ah that
is too sneaky man you knew that was
coming
haha I resign
ah man they were predicting my pre moves
and stuff you can't do that yeah that's
the drawback with berserk and AH man
crazy we're not even at the halfway
point yet
John Madden again let's try b3 it's
Castle and a pin point h2 does that
every time
let's get d5 in there we go now we're
going to hit the Queen and then be a
super pest here no he might have played
Knight g4 alright let's go here and get
it that e6 square this should be winning
should be let's get here rook here nexts
pretty deadly they resigned back to
I needed that 22 I'm fighting for third
can I get third these threes are nice I
like the trees okay here we go
threes and fives a mouse lips to Cillian
to start beautiful abort abort abort
okay there you go take out their dark
square Bishop just don't move bishop
there you go
and gonna have to castle don't oh listen
you already moved your king buddy he who
locks your cat's League privilege might
be 5 is a dagger and a half yes it is
Knight takes pawn with check me up here
this is collapsing though isn't it what
no no I could take that night it's just
winning how's the clock not good ooh
this is looking really juicy seven
seconds I have the corner square covered
I should have this should why am I not
getting rid
their bishop if you can't win this
oh my god completely I don't know if I
should complete that sentence if you
can't with this there's something wrong
you had seven Queens on the board man no
that was - you're exaggerating again
that's what happens okay
uh I can't even see now I can't even see
I'm going blind I'm going blind some ah
ah man let's throw a knight in that
square man it's a good square it's a
very good square have five I get here
what's with this position on this I'm
doing I should have taken with my queen
on the night I'll take that rook queen
sack there you go
light squares man light square attack
because you have all day you have all
day to win this one right on the Queen
and the rook looking for mating nets
where are the mating nets maybe not too
long off actually 11 seconds Oh their
queen is protecting that okay I have to
try and win this one on time hmm
mmm not happening again
oh man that's what you signed up for
back to tournament 11 minutes left
mmm 22 starting to be there yeah too
tough to even catch third to get third
there 1110 the newly crowned nm is here
okay oh here we go
Queen d2 get the dark square Bishop Soph
I have to stop playing positional and
have time for positional stuff I don't
have time for positional stuff
give him a boot and maybe I just
sacrifice
yikes that's a tsunami of pawns got to
get my C pawn rolling clean check cut
break this down here Queen up - maybe
it's anchor my knight in there okay rook
c6 discoveries maybe oh they're thinking
they are a thinking
to play rook c8 aren't they moving their
bishop behind a pond yiiikes
okay I got a draw at least and that's
what's gonna be a draw
oh I'll take it stop the bleeding
somewhat stop the bleeding okay 28
they're not 38 I see I can't see I
wasn't kidding my contacts are bothering
me man my contacts are bothering me
there's another excuse why not ah one
excuse is not enough now he's just he's
an excuse artist an excuse artist I
don't want to ever see you playing
berserk again all you end up doing is
making excuses and yeah alright my
light-square bishop do something
dangerous man I need your help I
definitely need your help weaken your
dark squares right because you have a
dark square Bishop break down those
light squares now we're talking Queen
takes here's what I want really soon ten
seconds Knight here is maybe juicy who
are we getting mate I think we are I
think we still are getting me Knight d5
was necessary no that's not me I'm
mistaken that's equivalent to resigning
isn't it
I gotta get pushing keep pushing
come on man you could do it they
resigned I love that oh man you should
test my mouse but I guess they they're
like a subjectively lost let's just
resign let's move forward save that
second I'll take it all right all right
my night does a little dance there we're
going to get d6 in that's a bit
exchanged indigo queenside is that your
plan I'll take that pawn we're going to
go Queen side uh-huh
maybe I should go with b5 go after their
King let's try this
there we go
right in here maybe no matter what king
up need to connect rooks get pushing my
pawns some more
was a bad free move huh actually I have
maybe a time edge now I do have a time
edge but I'm down ejected Lee clearly
all right no that's that's a pin buddy
you can't do that
oh no they're in time they only have one
second oh did I get it I got it oh I had
eight seconds sorry sorry about the lack
of commentary you're just gonna have to
understand you know you're just gonna
have to understand I'm pressed for time
you know what I mean a little pressed
for time oh let's give that Bishop of
boo now we're cooking we're going to
have a sneaky discovered a sneaky
discovered attack they anticipated it
hey don't be afraid to take a free pawn
every now and then you know it's not a
bad idea
inching into these dark squares oh yeah
so getting nervous now it's tense gonna
play f6o kings canoeing start flying a
ring-around-the-rosy tactic my knight
needed some defense oh close to giving
mate here let's make sure this file
opens up we got this not doing too bad
on the clock either even on the clock
King was flushed towards the center oh
they moved and I didn't see it clean
here that's illegal
oh no oh boy
please no time burners I got it back to
tournament less than four thank God
thank God it's less than four and this
is almost over I'm in fourth somehow I
might get third whoa get out of here I
would love to see a pony makes me a
podium experience yeah nice little
grammar lesson going on and everything
just a little bit of everything wrapped
into one here okay yes I know it's
coming
hmm and I guess we're gonna push here
yeah right here is where you push go
after their king your dark squares are
very weakened I'm talking about my my
own dark squares and let's break here
okay it's a passed pawn
come on man it's important it's
important they resigned back determine I
think I would have managed that okay I
stud for seconds and I am in third
somehow with less than two and this guy
doesn't have fire oh it's looking nice
for the podium that's what I meant to
say a podium a podium appearance only
several minutes later did I realize that
that is what I meant to say okay ah
that's a free bishop
give me that bishop they can't castle
get out of their night no counseling
still they're going to try to get
counseling in they will manage now fish
up here all right Knight here grab that
pawn let's take there first and here
then they're an activity get to the
seventh frame of that I just want to get
rid of their tricky night how can I make
that happen how could I not up it end up
in a fork there we go you got it now run
pawn you're fast actually need a little
help he would have been hunted down
there you go 28 seconds you got this
no stalemates got it whoo back to
tournament I will take it and that's
going to do it not going to get paired
up again 15 seconds left
finished off with the
five-game winning streak I needed I
definitely needed that one
oh man that's gonna do it man
54 46:44 38 38 33 32 29 29 28 all right
who else took part in this one 487 at
the end of this created tournament the
bird tournament see page 2 3 4 5 6 & 9
there we go all right to the 87 of you I
took part in this games all berserk land
all right
you